[Music]
the straw
what don't you like about the straw it
might already be because
uh i i'm a little hot right now because
i have the heat pad on yeah which by the
way i noticed
just recently that that's not a part of
your outfit that's a hot pack that you
have
that smells like tea on your shoulders
so i thought the shirt that you were
wearing just came custom
with a type of tarp on the shoulders no
you know what it is i've been putting a
lot of good sleeping hours lately and
when i go hard with the sleep i usually
pull something
now you are a guy and with the sleep
apnea mask which i
am going for a sleep test hopefully the
next two weeks and i can also have a
sleep apnea mask and then if i also get
the sleep apnea mask we will do an
episode with the masks on
[Laughter]
we should and then we will go on the
road together we'll have dueling we got
to make sure there's abundance of
outlets yeah because you actually when
every time you travel on the road you
have you have an own your own
compartment for the sleep apnea
equipment
it is the worst thing in the world right
so i can't fall asleep without it and
even if i do it's
bad sleep and then the next day i'm
liable to crash my car
so this is a long time i've been doing
this but you understand
i take like i don't like people take for
granted sleep but like
if i even have to go somewhere just
overnight yeah i gotta pack equipment
equipment and then when it's time to go
to bed and by the way when it's time to
go to bed you're usually tired
and you don't set it up ahead of time
you're like dead tired and you gotta get
up and then you gotta like unpack the
equipment
so i set it up and like and then put it
on once it's on it's no big deal but let
me ask you a question
you you um uh two i have two
i have two prong questions i have two
questions after i just tell you
i want to look into the camera this is
my camera and say i absolutely support
the environment
i've done jokes about this but the paper
straws
absolutely suck i've i've as you can see
drank 75 of my ice cream i still have a
healthy amount left and i can get
no liquid out of the straw now because
it's paper and it sucks
and there needs to be another option
until then i'll kill the turtles
i understand that what people need to do
though is if you're gonna take it
seriously
you gotta we gotta why has no one
researched a paper show with a little
clear coat on it or something i have no
idea something like you know
in christmas vacation i think clark
griswold he made like a protector
crystal he made a protectant for the
cereal that i think that's what he did
at his job where
i could be mistaking this but i think
that he made a protectant so that the
cereal doesn't get
soggy and milk and there was a coating
on it okay do it with the goddamn straw
just do it with the straw
i know i agree yeah what was clark
griswold's job
for the cereal okay we'll find it
um uh never um um it's true
they they get limp in like five minutes
and i mean
is it that big an issue to make the yeah
paper straw that works
i want to tell you something now and i
think it's something that you may not
know in addition to
not eating pork chops never seen the
movie the godfather never been having
goat cheese i've also never seen the
movie a christmas story
oh yeah i've never seen a favorite movie
of all time it's on for
24 hours a day every christmas and i've
never seen
a second all 24 hours is on in my house
for as long as they've done it
it's like a decade at least every time
it comes on it's on 24 7. my family
gets annoyed with me right but for me
it's like i don't want to see anything
else
you know what i don't have to watch it
here's what we're gonna do yeah we're
gonna can i lay this on this table like
this or is that no good because it does
have coffee in the truck
just all the tequila in the carpet for
me when i
drink tequila baby i still need you
i don't even know that song you don't
know that song i know you don't know
dan and shay oh you know hey i know shay
i know
shout out shay shout out shay when i
drink
that doesn't get radio play oh i don't
listen to the radio that's why i don't
even know
wow yes hey babe yeah i know
and also this is like a good to kill you
you really shouldn't drink it in in
the coffee you know what who cares who
gives a [ __ ]
i know that this may be timely who knows
when this is coming out but you know
what it doesn't matter anymore
the secretary of defense of the nation
of israel
a top western nation well i don't know
if they're a western nation but the
the the jew the the head jewish nation
just said
that the aliens exist and there's a
galactic federation
that has been waiting for humans to
reach a stage where we will understand
what space and spaceships are
this is coming from who is the former
head of the space program for the nation
of israel so if i could put a little
tequila in my coffee
no this is a good sign no is it a good
sign that they haven't destroyed us
according to nbc news you told me this
right before we hit record yeah and i
almost [ __ ] my pants yeah yeah
i know is this this is a reliable source
this is nbc news
chuck scarborough works for him
you got to take it off by the way it
smells like tea this thing it smells
delightful
and i got it at a mom-and-pop shop it
weighs like 10 pounds too it really
there's not a person in this world who
spent more money at mom and pop
and thrift stores than sell i know it's
you you support your local business yeah
it does it smells like uh like a ginger
tea a turmeric
hey babe sleeping i used to be physical
therapist
i can help you out i know i know what i
would tell you to do for right now
are you rusty do you forget [ __ ] are you
like oh [ __ ] that's called the uh
well you know what the thing is i am
rusty and there have been multiple
times where somebody has asked me for
advice and i've confidently
gave them advice and told them the wrong
thing to do but because it sounds so
why did you do that did you not feel
guilty i did for example what
why what made you feel like you couldn't
tell them i don't know
well no no well no the thing is i did
tell the i because i was confident in
the moment that what i was telling them
was correct and i texted them then after
and said everything i told you to do
just do the opposite
for example and i can mention the show
he's fine with it great friend of the
show
i do a podcast with him the great
giannis pappas had an elbow injury
yeah and i told him and i told giannis
what he had was was something called
tennis elbow
right which is lateral epicondylitis but
what he actually had was little league
elbow which is medial epicondylitis
so i gave him the exact wrong movement
to do
because it's the exact opposite side of
the heel notice now
the differences between little league
elbow and tennis elbow have been debated
for years
i've never heard a little league elbow
is that pitchers or just kids throwing a
ball when they're not developed yet
right little league elbow but it's the
medial
medial epicondylitis so middle means the
middle of the of the elbow
yeah and tennis elbow or is lateral
epicondylitis also called nurse mate
telbo
i've never heard of that yeah because
made yeah because they would pull
children antiquated thing is that what's
a nurse made a nurse yeah it's it's old
school stuff don't tell me they used to
be nurses and maids
well when they would pull they would
pull children quickly and they would
their elbows up hey babe they would have
babied their elbows up yeah
so you're telling me nurse made elbow
yeah it's not something that
people with the nurse made profession
got it's something that children got
because people that had a nurse made
profession abused
physically abused the child you as the
adult you could you could be the
you could get nursemaid's elbow never
being a nursemaid and you could also get
tennis elbow never playing tennis
and you get literally gobble right now
even though you're a grown man
that's embarrassing yeah you know what i
mean like it's just like why don't they
call it for like over 15 they call it
major league baseball
yeah could you imagine you go to a
doctor and he says well you have his
little league elbow
bro
no but but what is what is a nurse made
just what is the nurse nurse mate is
someone who's employed to
care for young children oh really yeah
like like uh
pick a name and go with it that's what i
say i mean are they amazing well now we
call them i guess an au pair right or
oh is that what it is i mean yeah
a woman or girl employed to look at by
the way they're johnny
they should nanny but they should they
should update this to
they should update this to um a
cisgender
person a cisgendered woman employed to
look after no how would they say this
right because right now it says a woman
or a girl
employed to look after young child to
children they're assuming
that a woman is biologically born as a
woman and has to be that to employ
to be employment of this so i just want
to clarify i don't know the exact thing
i got better for you what if a male
wanted to look after children that's
what i'm saying he called
or yeah nurse nurse um
nurse dude well nanny well the guy could
be a nanny that could be that can
you indicate gender no it shouldn't but
it might if i was a nanny and i had
nanny friends because you know how like
dog
there's like there's like a circuit of
nannies like you have to say yeah yeah
they all know each other they refer each
other like if i was like a nanny i would
start like a podcast with my other nanny
friends like and and
talk about all the things people don't
know like the day
of shenanigans shenanigans
trademark that payment if you could
trademark that right now get the lawyers
my question to you is sal i told you i
had a two-pronged question that i want
to ask you about sleep apnea
and also if you can mark this pimp i
also want to have a question about the
aliens
so the first question let's do the
question about the aliens first
when the aliens because now we are being
pretty much told that they are here and
i think that
the only way i think we're a very
divided nation for many different
reasons right now and the only way to
unify
us the world is to have a common enemy
which might be the aliens i understand
that so so that's
so so that's my hunch there but secondly
they're listening also they are they're
listening so just keep
what you say here it's going we don't
know i don't know if they get our humor
do they get our like well no no from
what does this man say what did he say
he says that they're among us right now
it's not like they're walking the earth
they're in they're in
bread in society he's saying here that
they're on government contract to do
experiments on us
and trump knows it and almost blew the
secret right
i mean and there's something and there's
this guy is saying trump almost blew a
secret and he's blowing the whole secret
yeah because well because if he goes
down he's saying he's saying look five
years ago if i would have come out in
public and say this
i'd be putting a mental institution but
now because the the public pretty much
knows what i'm saying is most likely
true
i feel as if i can say it because we are
very close
to the aliens accepting that we are
ready to listen to this
so and he's that's right if i said 15
years ago this you'd be like
no way you're crazy but now you actually
believe that this year
every like few weeks they were like yeah
aliens are around the aliens are around
so because because in other words when
15 years ago i would say
most likely there are no aliens and you
got to be crazy but now you ask a normal
person they'll say of course there are
aliens we just don't know
you know i think you're right as a
society we are not only
in agreeance but like in a weird
acceptance of it it was always like this
big mystery and if you were conspiracy
theorist if you thought that there might
be
with the roswell in the area but now
it's like there's just there's just
footage of it it's obvious
it's like the the ufo clip of the week
comes out so my question to you
is when aliens when they finally do come
out and say do
do do they have gender are there gender
identity politics with aliens
wow because i want to be followed i'm a
very forward person a very progressive
person
i want to know do there's no way for me
to know
so they're it's safe to say then that
they are they are
light years ahead of us in whatever
they're doing because they've been able
to keep themselves
from right our our our
our world at large everything is
government like everything is
sealed so they have to be more advanced
than us
yes which i think the age-old question
and you see it in movies is
if they come are they going to be
hostile are they not and
i got to say this is probably a good
sign that we have not been
demolished by them according
yeah but i would have read that and i
would have said you know you know hey
like there's a band there's a band i
don't know what i love their music it's
it's
h a i am but it's kim is the name game
him and one yeah one of my friends one
of my friends used to date one of the
girls
and uh and and um i'll tell you
off-camera who it is you know and and
and he used to date one of the girls and
he said that it's their their their
group is pronounced
hey listen i i got it loud and clear
yeah yeah
i'm just trying to confidently say it
like i said literally it is um wild when
you're not used to the dialects like
right when you when you say his name
you're flowing and then you say his name
it's almost like a speed bump it's a
speed bump
your whole body stops you say his name
and then you can have to be like well
according to
him a shed right and then i could go
back i'd be speaking of my limit you'd
be coked up and you'd probably be a
quarterback
came a shed and then
yeah i know i was listening too to
another thing um today about
uh a chinese executive was talking about
something about
donald trump and he was talking in
chinese but then like when he said
godzilla he was like you know donald
trump
and then yeah yeah yeah so it's it's an
interesting interesting thing
um so so and bloomberg used to do like
half the report
with the spanish i did you admire that
it was one of the funniest things that i
ever heard but he was doing that
he was really okay what percentage of
him was doing that
to connect relate and and and and be
progressive with the
the latino and spanish communities that
we have especially abundance of new york
and what was that what part of that was
like
i'm flexing and i'm taking a spanish
class
because his also his annunciation was
very much
junior in high school when you're like
yo
let's listen to uh
[Music]
uh
sounds like it sounds like he's just
reading the words right but he has
no idea what they mean like someone
typed out and he was like exactly like
like la biblioteca like yeah yo tango
michael bloomberg
yeah yeah no it and it's funny as soon
as as soon as when pimp put in mayor
bloomberg speaking spanish came up right
away
yeah because i mean people laugh at this
all you have to do like some serious
addressing
sometimes sometimes it'd be like a
poignant moment or something that he was
addressing that was a more serious
subject matter yeah and then just
launch into yeah like you know nosotros
vosotros
yeah which yeah i i so yeah i don't know
may i miss sometimes i miss mary
bloomberg
the only thing that i didn't like he did
a good job i mean he tried to like tell
people like
i'll tell you the takeaways of laura i'm
not into politics like you per se
and i'm neces not like as steeped in it
right so like
my takeaways from things like his whole
term i remember like that
one of the most like i'm like bloomberg
yeah spoke spanish tried to keep people
from buying big gulps
that's what i remember no that's like
his legacy if you told me
100 if you told me that i would say yeah
he tried to ban sodas and spoke spanish
like an idiot
that's exactly what i'd say by the way
great socks today who is this on the
sock
that this is uh this is uh will this is
the fresh prince of bel-air
oh wow fantastic socks i'll tell you
right now first uh
maybe first time i've ever wear them
ever wearing them perfect you know who
sent it to me stance
yes stance best socks they didn't send
it to me that's who this is you doing
who sent me these who
the first prince of bel air are you
serious i swear to christ oh because
because of jaden smith no i don't know
him i didn't know him at the time oh
wait maybe he knew who i was
but i got a box and it was the will
smith the fresh prince
for jordan fives and these socks from
will smith himself to sal
like enjoy like and it said like you
know from like will smith
but i had a friend who was working for
his uh production company i think i have
a couple of friends
jf harris comic shout out jf harris he
was working
he's like i'm i'm doing some writing for
will smith and he goes uh he goes
he has some stuff for staff i'm gonna
see if i could get you something i'm
like sure and then i just got a package
from will smith
no dude it's uh they're great socks and
great do you still have those kicks or
no
the will smith's yeah i got them do you
wear them or no i i'm not a white
shoe guy especially a high-top chunky
white shoe guy
i already do not wear the white shoes
because of the privilege i have
yeah i just don't wanna i i don't i
don't wanna whitewash my
you know my entire album right no um but
no i i just i don't have the body for it
my feet i disagree my feet go out and i
just look like i'm i'm wearing these two
big like
it calls too much attention to the
motion and the shape of my foot
right i told you because you said you
were keto and when you were 30 to 40
pounds lighter
i didn't like you like that i like the
sound like this you look healthier and
you feel more like sal like this
you're a sweet kid and you're a good
friend and you're smart and you're
educated and i appreciate that opinion
but i will take 40 pounds lighter and uh
fair enough that's what happened
like i'll do it but then what happens
there's no danger of keto yeah
if you're not keto dangerous shout out
keto if you're not strict
um you're doing high fat
very low carb right right um and some
protein but mostly fat
and uh saturate like say high in fat and
then if you
deviate and you're like i did keto all
day but then you just have a slice of
cake
the keto is done your body goes out of
ketosis now you ate
yes that but also now you ate sugar and
a ton of fat
and it's just like you you have to be
strict one way but once you start
dabbling
in the sugar and mixing it with keto now
you're just eating bad
got it so right i mean the carbs and
sugar are fine but like
you know you know keto some people
question if keto is healthy as it stands
right because it's like just you know
but right it does it does
one thing one way but the second yeah
you risk okay could cause
keto diet could cause low blood blood
blood pressure kidney stones
constipation nutrient deficiencies and
an increased risk of heart disease
but you will be ripped but you'll be
ripped yeah so that's the dif
so if you want to get ripped you could
do keto but understand kids the minute
you bite into a cupcake which i did a
red velvet that came from a friend of a
friend's wife do you have them right
here today
i i had one it wasn't that good i threw
out the other one out there watching i'm
sorry
sorry about this you know one of your
cupcakes it was it was like if i'm being
honest if they're watching i don't know
it was good but it wasn't worth it you
know what it could use
saratoga peanut butter not a sponsor but
just want to give a shout out mom and
pop shop maybe one day maybe they throw
some all away yeah
this is like you killed kenny for us
yeah yeah yeah
yeah he comes up once every year yeah
um uh yeah so no no so hey babe
keto and aliens yeah you think alien you
think
you think that okay the aliens right how
how how parallel are they to our society
you think he got a chunky alien on a
diet
that's i think yes because i think what
what
what ham ahead is has said what he's
alluded to
yeah is that they are among us and have
been among us for years he said two
things that are wild
he said they've been among us for years
and actually have infiltrated
into our human race already so there may
be people out there
that have alien dna have to be
absolutely kidding me this is
how they remain and how they remain in
plain sight you gotta be kidding me no
he said that and then
my god every time i laugh like that yeah
i
fully get completely blacked out i i
blocked flashes of blackout
this can't be healthy no i'm just eating
so much fat with the keto
and i go to laugh i wheeze and literally
for like two to
four seconds blacked out i get blacked
out and i fully get like
queasy and i come back too you almost
like go to alternate realities and then
you come back
[ __ ] dude so what he said what he said
is
is that number one infiltrated among us
number two
right now present day he said this dead
series to the camera
former head of this of the space program
of the nation of israel
him ahead said right now in 2020 right
now
there is a base 20 miles below the
surface of mars with american astronauts
and aliens right now doing experiments
right now
hold on hold on this is real how many is
the nation
like if i look out my window there'll be
people just throwing molotov cocktails
how is the nation receiving this right
now i mean joe rogan's going nuts
he's going up yeah but like i don't i i
but wait why is he
is he like i don't care i'm doing it is
he getting in trouble for is this
confidential we're about to find out
we're about to find out
this guy is just whistleblowing if you
go down pimpy if you could scroll down a
little bit
um um is he is he right now being picked
up by like men in black suits because
he just spilled the beans he said there
was an agreement look
there's an agreement between the us
government and the aliens they signed
the contract to do experiments
ashad said cooperation agreements have
been signed between species including an
underground base in the depths of mars
where they're american astronaut
american astronauts and
alien representatives representatives
yes
and american astronauts
we're being lied to we've launched
people to so we've been to
mars wait we have been to mars we have
not been tomorrow's
over the rovers there yeah but we never
thought we have a reminder
elon musk was going to mars i thought
that was going to be the first one why
are we 20 feet
why are we 20 miles down in mars why not
just be like on a cul-de-sac
so could he not be an alien who do you
think aliens could be
right like this guy wait hold on hold on
he's not like a randy quaid type
let me just clarify one thing quickly
homeless pimp
did not just insinuate that jews are
aliens fyi he did not insinuate that
even though it sounded like that
we are not saying jews are aliens on
this show we are saying that potentially
the head of the space program from
israel could be an alien donald trump
wasn't
donald trump is aware and had been on
the verge of revealing
oh because maybe he wants to go out this
mug with a mic drop
yeah you imagine well that's what
they're saying he was about to be like
you know but what does that do
why would he take it up just send
himself to reveal it to us what if we
anger
the pact that we have with the alien
representative well that's why that's
why
it says president trump was aware of the
extraterrestrials in existence and had
been on the verge of revealing
information
but the aliens asked they'd not do it in
order to prevent man cysterius so the
aliens
aliens talk to trump so wait so the
aliens are also they're on whatsapp like
what's
like the aliens so they're like we're
communicating with them
i wonder if they are so ahead of us that
they just use
is that infiltrated among us because
they're shapeless because they're just a
brain because they've evolved to not
even need their bodies
and they're just they're just shaping
they've been able to take on like so
they could see you in your room when
you're alone in your house alone
they they could or they've taken the
shape of a you i'm not
cue could be an alien are you come on
dude so
everything we know now is is is
questionable that's
that's why he's saying that's why
they've been saying like you you can't
master what is saying pentagon the
pentagon confirms aliens are real
but and that just came and went they did
that right in the middle of coronavirus
in the summer that's when they were like
just do it now just do it now because
otherwise people would have been just
punching each other in the chops well
it's just because there's
times this is no longer in the shadows
pentagon's ufo unit will make some
findings public
whoa the naval intelligence of the
united states
why wouldn't trump just fire off a tweet
though what about this
what about while they stood idly by and
let people be roundly mocked ridiculed
and called crazy for decades and decades
and decades you were like
they probed my ass
ptsd out out the ass yes
you know and this guy's telling everyone
to listen and everyone's like this
wackadoo yeah i mean while he got up the
ass no one listens
somebody's in an insane asylum right now
for years
actually the truth that's wild yeah well
how much of the stuff that we've gleaned
in popular culture and movies and
fiction
uh like uh you know being pulled up and
probed and
shape-shifting do you think stems from
leaks from what people
really know or how much do you think
we've just
assumed and guessed and this could be
everything that an alien is could be
a 100 departure from every single
version we've ever thought up in our
minds now i am not i'm being 100 on
studio right now
i would say the likelihood that most of
the things we see
in the movies are are based off real
life from some top
level person are so high it's incredible
i
very very i do not think that the human
being just made
little green men and things about aliens
up from their own head i believe that
some of it is creative license but
there's also some of it that was based
off a high-ranking official
spilling something to someone in
hollywood honestly i can't believe
it took this long for someone to be like
i gotta tell you something
like i don't know i'm gonna break the
secret like everyone was like just kept
it so tight even they said even area 51
was like a hoax it was [ __ ]
i wonder if crop circles [ __ ] well
area 51 what they say with the with the
the conspiracy on that is that area 51
does exist
but it only exists so people focus on
area 51 when the actual react
real alien stuff is happening in another
place
so they won area 51 go ahead please
storm arrows
nothing's happening here i understand so
but but please look they got the guards
there and they got the signs
right because you're like oh actually
it's happening at areas yeah it's hap it
happens at area 52.
what is that conversation like when by
the way before you are the president
you're you're you're a laper you're a
civilian every minute before you call
the president
so every president they had to have the
talk with what's that like someone comes
in and like trump just walks in his
first day of office they're like
a seat close the door bob
donny um mr president
if i tell you something yeah is it like
how like
is it like do me a favor like just i'm
going to tell you something right now
yeah just do me a favor just give me a
big pig
do you know what it honestly might be i
know it's just gonna it's another thing
that's crazy and crazy conspiracies and
it's crazy i genuinely believe that
they probably tell the president these
secrets and say
if you spill them we will kill your
family like if you spill them
you're gonna so it's gonna be so bad
like something's gonna happen bad that's
why
i really think god forbid i don't know i
don't know government i talk in my sleep
i don't know what the hell yeah
speaking of sleep i want to get back to
one more question with the sleep apnea
two prong questions yeah yeah number one
it's a very slow deliberate double prong
number one yes with the sleep apnea
masks
do you feel do you find i want you to
answer both back to back
do you feel since you've had the sleep
apnea mass
your sleeps are legit night and day
better i could sleep afterwards we might
have even spoken about this on this
podcast before a little bit well
sometimes we repeat
secondly have you ever had the sleep
apnea mask on
yeah and in the middle of the night
we've all been there sleeping with the
woman you have sex in the night have you
ever had sex with the sleep apnea mask
on
sure with a woman so i'll i'll be
starting with
the first prong uh i can't live without
the machine
okay uh if i do and i try to go to sleep
it'll be the most miserable night of my
life followed by the most miserable day
of my life
okay it works for me it took a little
getting used to it
at first now i don't even think about
that [ __ ] which is good it's just
annoying that i have to lug it all
around
because you're almost never tired i
ended up buying a lot of them
so i have one here i have one in my
suitcase so i never have to pack it up
guns yeah i hadn't stashed it right but
and then number two i have never no i
have never had
there's only been i think let me think
about this i think there's only been
two relationships in my life that i have
that i have been that i have said all
right you know i'm going to put this on
right in front of you
because it is a now more it's way more
common
right you see it i mean half the people
have it now it's way more like
people if you say it they know what it
is they know what even what it looks
like
right but when i got it for the first
time like 15 years ago and i'm sure it
was common then but not to me
and i and i which one do you have do you
have the one that goes up your nose like
one of them looks like like a like a
like a punter's helmet
and then the other one looks like you're
on a ventilator yeah so which one do you
have
i i have uh a moderate uh a a modified
ventilator one
got it it's it's like um it's it's
oh birth control that's meal number
three
see i'm supposed to be instead i'll just
drink tequila should we get the meal up
here
no we can get somebody to get the meal
up here oh it's fine it's fine yeah
this is crazy this thing but i i found
anyway if you get them yeah i've been
through so many that i actually have
some really constructive yeah i'll give
you some suggestions on what to get
because
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] ones out
there it depends what you come for
there's some that cover your whole
goddamn face
right some just up you know some just up
your mouth some right here like
we've discussed and we'll get we've
discussed that eventually on this show
we will eventually have a patreon on the
patreon when we
when we finally get there if i get the
sleep apnea mass too would you be
willing to take a selfie minion with the
sleep apnea mask put it up just for the
patreon
one million percent got it that's the
patreon and nobody will right click save
as
and nobody will put that up online
because there are pages
patients i got to be honest with you i
got to be honest with you
you know the history aina show we have
we've put up some of the most wild
things on patreon you could even imagine
it has never surfaced once because they
actually do feel like
well they actually are our family for
the show right so the people who
eventually join this patreon when we do
it
it they really truly like it is a it is
essential trust
your alien representatives yes
tight-lipped and no one's finding out
they know if they post it we will kill
their families right
that's what they know sal as you know
it's extremely difficult for me to get
erections that's been something i've
it's
a secret it's no secret i walk around
i'm crazy semis i just
i always have half a chub um chrissy
half a chub the reason why i have a
pillow over my pants right now
i took a blue chew last night i'm hard
as a rock right now is that right
i sal my pillow was for comfort no no
i'm literally hiding an erection
that i've had for the first time in a
couple of days that's what happens with
bluetooth because guess what i went
i went to bluechew.com that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com bluetooth.com i put in the promo
code hey babe
i got it for free all i had to do was
pay five dollars for the shipping which
it's
it's five dollars for shipping it's the
holidays five dollars you know how many
things you can get off the dollar menu
for that
uh i would say five about yeah you know
bluetooth is made in the usa it's
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor or
wait in line beautiful it's even cheaper
than a pharmacy
right uh they have and they prepare and
ship it right to you in a discreet
package there's no awkwardness
that's what happens you have to leave
the house to me nobody in my house knew
at all not even my own daughter
knew that the packages that she was
giving to daddy what to give daddy a
boner yeah i like it
it says what it is right in the name
it's right in the blue and you're gonna
chew it and that's all it is
and for the holidays what's better than
having a boner for the holiday season
there's not much
again it's b-l-u-e-chew.com
you put in promo code hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e hey babe to try it
free and you're going to want to order
now if you want it in time for the
holiday one time holidays and i
guarantee you this i guarantee you this
right now
santa claus himself has taken a blue
chew fully expect him to get stuck in
your chimney because he will have a
boner from blue cheese if not
maybe don't leave him cookies maybe
leave some blue juice or instead of
chocolate chips bake the cookie with a
blue chew in there and then santa leaves
it very happy
bluechew.com promo code hey babe you get
it for free
five dollars shipping stay hard happy
holidays
sal you know who i love who do you love
lucy
the girl from around the way no the
nicotine alternative lucy
lucy yes lucy hello it's a nicotine
alternative
that i found and then i've actually i
have an aunt you know my aunt colleen
she smokes a lot
and i tried to get her to quit because i
said listen it's 20 20 i mean what are
you doing aliens are out i mean there's
a pandemic
you got to stop smoking i got her on
lucy the woman hasn't smoked in three
weeks
is that right the nicotine alternative
she's chewing the gum you got to do it
now we know too much about cigarettes
and they're not good for you and here's
the thing with gum
normally what do you got two flavors of
greens you got your cinnamon winter
green guess what lucy also has you ready
for this yeah pomegranate
shows me they're innovating i i told my
aunt eileen i said pomegranate is good
for the process she said i'm a woman i
said well i have a low iq
yeah well we'll see you know also that
they have a lozenge and cherry ice
flavor as well
you can suck on a lucy you could suck on
it especially now during the winter
months
what's better than a lucy lodging it's
the real deal a subscription of lucy
comes directly to your door each month
it's so simple you don't have to leave
your house because lucy has delivery
down listen normally when someone named
lucy comes to my house i've made an
illegal transaction
this time it's fine it's legal all you
got to do is go to lucy
dot co that's lucy.co and use the promo
code
hey babe at checkout there you're gonna
get five percent off ten percent fifteen
percent
are you kidding me i was being serious
you're gonna get it's 20 20 you're
getting 20 percent off what
including the gum and the laws you're
just insane now yeah hey
you're giving it away the promo code is
hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e the website
is lucy dot co if you put the m in it
you're making a mistake you're not gonna
get anything
it's lucy dot co promo code haybay also
i had to give this disclaimer warning
seriously the product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco
and nicotine is an addictive chemical
that's what we know what we're doing
here this is this is
this is to to to to come off the signal
to come off this
and that's what it is i'm going to try
the gun myself as soon as i see i'm
going to see aunt colleen for christmas
because i say listen i don't smoke
necessarily but i want to chew the gum
just because it's flavorful
and it's a nicotine alternative and i
always think that's a good thing go to
lucy.com promo code
hey hey babe and you make a good point
i'm gonna go see my family for the
holidays i have a
few people that smoke there i'll bring
it up because i didn't have anything to
argue with them about up till now
there it is yeah lucy dot co promo code
hey babe
yeah so no i i don't uh yeah so i've
never had
okay i never had any real time on the
drive over yeah well you really i'm
gonna send one of saliva at sex with the
apne master make sure you get yourself a
humidifier built in
which is kind of like a standard part of
the course now when i
when i when i came up yeah when i was
coming up yeah uh
we did not have humidifiers and so you
put that [ __ ] on and then
honestly in like one hour you felt like
you were gonna die like you you
your trachea esophagus lips gums was
like it was almost like you were in a
sarcophagus like you could and then
you're going to drink water and then go
for another hour and put it on but now
it's a humidifier this is
you know i'm sure everybody wants me to
talk about the humidity
22 million americans suffer from sleep
apnea i would think a percentage of our
listeners haven't yeah so for those of
you
who are who this is appropriate to
you're welcome you're welcome
it is what it is it is what it is what i
know it's very interesting it's i mean
dude how do i know you're not an alien
can you prove it it's a good point i
can't can i prove it
how would you prove it to me how would i
prove it to you right how would you
prove it
there are healthy majority of people who
no matter what will not get coveted
could they be the aliens
the ones who've never gotten it what
about this they're very hands-off
if they are superior to us in terms of
intellect emotion
technology and what spirituality
everything
why do you think do you think they're
just like this is not our world to touch
or do you think they have already we
just don't know it like why would they
if they are a superior being and they
see strife
and famine and sickness and poverty and
discord and things like that
you don't think anyone's up there being
like should we help them well well
what israel what the israeli said is
that
is that they the reason why they're here
is to study the universe just like us so
they're peaceful and they're trying to
fight some of these same questions we
have about the universe and
disease and all that they have too from
their planet so that's what
that is so it's not like they are so
superior i mean obviously they have to
be somewhat superior they got to our
planet
yeah but and we didn't i uh man from
what how
fact does this even go well that that
was gonna be my next question when you
my next thing when you say how do you
know if your aliens
how do you how do i know you're not an
alien i wonder if the people are
our aliens even though they're aliens
wow
is that is that to watch
that's what i'm thinking you know we
don't know
yeah i mean what what technology was
made by them
how about this how about this it stands
to reason because of the infiniteness of
the universe
that they don't know about [ __ ] there's
advanced
species and cultures greater than them
where they're like i wonder if there's
anyone besides the 200 we know about
and there's a million more million more
you know how about this
is there a whole interconnected universe
that's talking and we're the only ones
left out of it
that's true well it's like when are we
going to let them know that shit's going
down
all across the universe right like it's
a galaxy is it one of those what's
bigger a universe or a galaxy
the universe they get we are the year
and the milky way galaxy is all right
and there's only and there's actually a
million universes right have you ever
seen the video
of what they of when they zoom out of
how small earth is
infinitely bigger sometimes when i
really get high
yeah i put it on when you're smoking
this if you've watched it like five or
six times yes
yeah this and there's there's one where
they explain to you how small we
actually are
yeah then there's another version of
that milky way galaxy is one of billions
of universes
the end of the milky way galaxy is how
far hundreds of millions of light years
how big is the milky way we we mean
absolutely nothing zero we mean nothing
we
are we are smaller than a speck of dust
so i mean the milky way is the radius
it's 52 850 light years so we know that
though that even sounds like [ __ ]
there's no way to know what tool what
tool do we have that's measuring that i
think about this
i think about this all the time if i was
a scientist if i was a scientist by the
way we're going to get in the comments
for this
people were furious when we didn't
realize where maggots came from yeah
people
now we're just shooting off with the
amounts of our opinions and these
armchair alien experts gonna come in and
be like you doofus we know about light
years because of the [ __ ] c5 yeah
okay so how does nasa know what our
galaxy looks like one gets a rough idea
of the shape of the milky way galaxy by
just looking around a ragged hazy band
of light circles in the sky
that observation indicates that our
milky way galaxy is a flattened disk of
stars
with us located somewhere near the plane
of the disk where not a flattened disk
it will look different i don't even know
what they just said i don't know
what they're talking about if i was a
scientist test with finding trying to
find out how big the galaxy was
i would just look at it look at my
computer for about four years and then
just pull a number out of my ass just
tell them how are you gonna fact check
that out just tell us something nobody
knows anything
and by the way how many people total
cumulative
scientists are that advanced that
they're in this conversation
there's what how many people billion
people on earth i think there's eight
billion billion is there eight billion
could be six billion yeah eight billion
right
so it was like seven at one point i
think now it's gotta be eight it's gotta
be especially with quarantine everyone's
having seven seven point six so we were
both right yeah yeah and that was in
2018 so who knows so who knows
yeah but out of 7.594 billion people
which also how accurate is that
exactly but out of that how many of
those people is it in the
thousands that are like i am a scientist
that is so smart and dedicated my life's
work to this so much that i am the
authority
that's telling you that the radius is 52
000 light years and all this other jazz
and all stuff
think about that how many people we
don't know any do you know any
no one i know knows anyone of that
caliber how many
of them are on the planet and if if one
dies
is it really taking a hit to what we
know as far as knowledge how are we
recording this information
who's getting passed along to who are
the people the kids walking around right
now
literally picking their own nose who are
going to become
the bearer and and and and the people
that pass on this information
it's a excellent way we're not doing it
we're not what are we doing we're doing
a headband podcast
i'm doing nothing i'm doing i know this
guy is telling
i mean we need people like this we need
to know who they all we need to lift
them up we need to lift them up
the only scientists i've ever met in my
life ever is neil degrasse tyson yeah we
did an episode with him on the history
on his podcast and all neil degrasse
tyson told me
is that if jeff bezos laid all his money
out in single dollar bills right now he
had
he'd had enough he would have enough
money to stretch
from los angeles to the moon and back
around 12 times and at the end of those
singles still have enough money left
over
to go from la to australia
in singles this is the guy from amazon
this is what neil degrasse tyson told me
yeah so that's so not for nothing but
neil you're one of these people that has
some of this type of knowledge
and your [ __ ] footing around doing
headbands and algorithms about dollar
bills and and bezos like
you he might have wasted a whole
afternoon on that when he could have
been looking up extra stuff about the
universe and then giannis
said to neil he said to him because neil
degrasse tyson started the episode by
saying there is no sense
what is his middle name neil degrasse or
is that a hyphenated last name
i think it's i think that's a good point
is this is degrasse a name
degrasse i think it's his middle name oh
a lower d
e with a capital g nev oh you almost
never see a lower d
e he's an astrophysicist and one one one
one day half the day he took being like
a dollar bill is about six inches long
times you know 80 billion
and he took up a whole like it's a whole
lunch break doing that calculation but i
like he's playing great i don't know
much about the man
he's a nice guy he said he said in the
beginning of the episode
that he was either going to
uh go to harvard which he eventually did
on a science scholarship or become a
male stripper
those were literally the two things he
said he was he was ripped
neil degrasse tyson shirtless teenager
stop shredded sound
like you jacked football player is he
like the equivalent of uh
like a modern day like i mean not a
philosopher
but is he like an albert einstein of our
day no
albert einstein dropped when we were so
primitive that
the work he did like how many albert
einstein equivalents are there today
i would say elon musk stephen hawking
who passed away
these people are so these are only the
few you could name well you know
there's plenty we don't know you got it
well there might be something
is is it albert einstein a one in a
billion person
or a one in a million person what is he
i'd say one in a billion and you have to
understand about the marketing einstein
and oppenheimer and all these were great
scientists thomas edison though
was a guy he was more of a businessman
everyone credits thomas edison but it's
really nikolai tesla's ideas
right that's why elon musk was very i
want to name my company tesla
to give him the recognition right and
elon musk is actually doing the work
there's
there's like now it's like elon musk is
a modern day einstein neil degrasse
tyson is
is extremely intelligent but i don't
know that he's doing the work
that an elon musk is gonna go to mars
are creative geniuses born or made what
are the chances of being born a genius
genius is born only on average what are
the chances of happening thanks to your
question in general there is a small
chance of being positive
which sounds like a big chance well if
that's true
five percent of eight of almost eight
billion i mean five percent of eight
billion you're talking about
millions and millions of geniuses yeah
okay a normal
intelligence quotient ranges from 85 to
115 according to stanford
uh only a scale only approximately one
percent of the people in the world
have an iq of 135 or over genius or near
genus iq is considered to start around
to 145 less than one-fourth of one
percent falls into that category i've
never taken an iq test maybe either
i mean i've done them online can't be
accurate there's no way that's accurate
i'd like to get a
i'd like to do on the show a true iq
test
you wanna do it i'd like to do it yeah
if anybody knows how we could do it let
us know
the iq test they they will test things
that do not need to be studied for right
they test more like logic
can we get a sample question from an iq
test and let's just see if we can do it
yeah because yeah sample iq test
questions whatever because i don't even
know where to begin
like i wouldn't even know what to do
if it's state capitals i know everyone
yeah but that can't be iq because that
doesn't mean
does it does an iq memory it's
intelligence quotient it's not like
information that you have right examples
of of the iq test are analogies pattern
driven
and then classification visual spatial
logical how
long is it how long does it take to do
an iq test want to do them and then
compare it like you want to do in one
week if it's like a half hour yeah
and we'll just come back are you nervous
to find it's almost like taking a covet
test i know
and i'm like how dumb am i because god
forbid god forbid i'm a genius
god forbid no there's no way no i'm
scared of what i would rate right what
do you think oh how about this
how about this too we we we take we
gamble on what we think we might rate
right because i don't even know i don't
even i don't even know
okay i couldn't begin to guess where i
would fall on that scale yeah i
i if i had to guess i think i have a
nice emotional intelligence
i was gonna say i think we're we have to
be at least average intelligence
yeah we have to be right we have to be
at least average i don't think that i'm
above average i would say i'm average we
didn't know where maggots came from
that's true
yeah larvae yeah larvae by flies
[ __ ]
all right well you're watching you
you're watching us i don't know like
what i mean people still i mean every
time i open up my
my twitter i mean somebody's yelling at
me are you laughing i'm wearing will
smith soccer
i will smith's son tattooed on both of
my thoughts yes i have on twitter
jaden smith tattooed on both of my
thighs permanently for life
i have i have on two different socks
right now because i took a bluetooth
this morning and had a boner
the other sponsor that's why this is
here right now use the promo code hey
babe
whenever you tune in there's a pillow
here and here blue chew struck again
no i i have but you understand what i'm
saying like like does that do
like i i i you'd ask me about when i go
to bed
with the with the mask right i also have
a young a young boy a young artist on my
thigh
on my thighs yeah like i have a 15 year
old black and white jaden on the left
a full color 21 year old jayden on the
right right now i
really hope i don't get any more and
nothing against jaden if you watch
watching but like
i i um that's all my left life
the final season of the show if if if
if you know the fine when when it is a
great tattoo shout out to the i forget
that needles is the guy who did it
when it is confirmed look at the title
it's salvo no gay
well shut up oh my god that's a picture
of chris jericho look at this
christian wine he's wearing a shirt yeah
small world alien chris jericho alien
um uh am i gay no i'm not kay i know
that i
when i fool around sometimes i like to
be a little flamboyant it just i don't
know
it's something i picked up it's fun i
mean whether you get i mean jade
handsome handsome boy
yeah yeah but then i got the one on the
right by the way the one on the right i
got for the movie and i
excuse me if i mentioned this before but
it's even bigger it's in color it's
updated now it adds to because i have
them on both thighs
that came out in the movie not i think i
might have mentioned this to you to this
day to this day
right not one person when it came out on
the show i could not
escape it everyone who saw me he's like
take your pants down let me see a pan
i got the other one i was like here we
go again to this day
not a soul walking the face of this
earth has mentioned to me about the
other tattoo
well now they will after this episode i
mean it is what it is but
i'll tell you another thing imagine
dating somebody new
and who doesn't know the show and then
yeah and there's a and then there's
another show and then i have you know
a a talented young younger
african-american african-american adult
male 1
well i think what you should do to
complete the cycle is when it is
confirmed that this is the last season
of practical jokers if you lose
a a bet and you have to you should get
the adult version of jayden and then
that's it
then you have three versions i've heard
the idea turn around to which i'm
mortified at
that i i now have to keep up the pattern
of every five years
and just keep getting him until would
you consider that uh
i mean what am i doing though i don't
understand like there's no tv show joke
has been over for years and you're like
hey it's five years guys
rules are rules uh the girl like the
person i was dating at the time i got
the first one was
like i mean like really you can like
come on like i came home with it
yeah and then they will just like uh you
know i gotta i gotta look at that it's
weird
it's weird it's weird you know when
intimacy strikes it can it can be weird
it could be it could be strange but
still not weirder than intimacy with the
sleep happening that's true yeah
so but and then i've heard the other
thing is that i get the jada
uh and and the and and the willow and
the will
and i do a smith family mount rushmore
that'd be that'd be another where would
you get that if you if you had if that
was
just going around my thigh like it has
to you can only do the leg because i'm
not going to get another
jaden to be in the so they got to attack
on to this
i'm happy to do it i heard i know now
that they know about it and they're very
they were very pleasant and polite to us
and i
i heard that uh jayden actually told me
that they watched the show
together as a family once in a while
this was a couple years ago i don't know
he you know he might not even
you know right anymore but like yeah but
yeah i have that so
it would be amazing i just saw a little
thing and obviously it's fake but if
jayden one day
got a tattoo with you yeah if he ever
did that but talking about iqs and
talking about aliens looking down
on us i'm walking around and i'm putting
a mask on to sleep i got
you know i got children tattooed on me
like what is my iq
well yeah no i understand i understand
the thing is though
yeah but but i think to have a really
really like above average
iq like genius level iq there because
the universe is about balance yeah you
give up something else usually those
they don't have the greatest
personalities or they have some type of
phobia because they're so smart their
brains so hyperactive right i'd rather
be dumb
like i am now but enjoy life because i
don't really know what can affect me i'm
just saying i'm just you know looking
with with that knowledge comes like you
know you then you feel guilty it's like
are you gonna use this knowledge for the
greater good or not
right and then you got the weight of the
world rested on your shoulders my mother
the thing is with aliens is why my
because my mother is so
profoundly religious that if she
if she listens and i don't know that she
doesn't listen to
things in in hebrew or doesn't know
what's going on with israel but if she
heard hemashed's
recent kind of thing about aliens being
real
it would affect her in such a negative
way because then that completely
shatters her idea that she believes in
that the earth was made in seven days
and
right we're the only people and you know
because then create
what is god because if the aliens are
real then what is god is god the
does he also rule them right because
then that starts that's a big religious
uh uh uh conundrum right that people are
under now if she puts any stock into
what hamashed said
if she puts it to him you know i don't
know oh yeah we're gonna do that
yeah get that in it's not there's no way
to live and listen and the reason why
the pill is on the lap
is because obviously you know i have a
boner from blue chew
that's right um sponsor uh code you just
chew it
just chew it and that's it code hey babe
and then you just chew it and then
you're on your way to a
more fun you what do aliens do to our
history is an interesting thing because
how do we know that aliens what did they
just show up 20 years ago
did they did they help win the civil war
right
what have they done where what have they
done yeah are they are they like an
all-time assist leader and we don't even
know it did they build the pyramids as
are they isaiah thomas so john john
stockton yeah
yeah you know yeah i mean i don't know
they they must have built those then or
maybe they didn't i don't know what they
seem like
well they say the pyramids to this day
can't be built with the precision with
the modern machine we have today cannot
be built with the precision
that they were built in 2000 years ago
built with
2000 years ago to this day they can't
and also the the stone
was so thick it's so thick that it could
only have been cut with
diamond studded tools so either these
slaves
of the egyptians who who they think
built the pyramids were using diamond
encrusted tools i thought
they got help from the police system or
something no but they're saying
to engrave in the stone you have to have
a a sub
a thing that's harder than the stone and
the only thing harder than the stone
yeah you gotta go to jared you have to
go to jail you have to go to the gym
there was no jared okay back then
to my knowledge no no right those can
you confirm that one of those one of
those created those companies
yeah one yeah one was jared jared our
diamond
company created was it before and after
the pyramids let's just see
just because we want to okay okay 1910
well
that was actually that was earlier than
i thought it was
yeah but it wasn't it was seven it was
after the pyramid right right okay
what about k when did k start because
yeah see the pyramids now there you go
the appearance of 2550 bc
so we're off by about 44 or 4 500 years
so
it wasn't jared not terrible no um
um khufu is the tallest pyramid fyi if
you guys let me ask you a question now
so it stands to reason that
is there do you believe there is
enormous normalcy
within the alien species in and of
itself
or have they progressed to a point where
we don't even understand
what life becomes for them are they just
a big computer program running up there
like are they
are they do they have uh do they have
vices do they have joys do they have
recreation
do they have love do they have
relationships do they have you know do
they have
terror did like what like or are they
now just like
literally like just
an operational thing like you know well
if they're learning if they're coming
down here to learn
observe then that must
you know what i mean like is there an
alien it's like oh my god i can't stand
to look at myself with my shirt at all
yeah you know what i mean like it's an
interesting alien friend that's just
like don't even worry about it
you know what get you get your shoes on
let's go to earth because i'm going to
take you out for this i'm going to take
you out for the day
you're in a rut right now let's go down
there right now let's just fly around
go in the white house say like is this
is this a disney world or is it like
or is it like our aliens right now are
the aliens being sent who are on our
planet right right now
are they like the elon musk and stephen
hawkins of their world or
are they like some lower form that they
just sent out here or
are there like are they so smart that
like even their screeches are coming
down here
and like like right you know like like
they like they have
found a way to get to a wormhole or a
black hole and they could come here for
the day
freaking day they cut school come here
go home right their parents don't even
know that they're gone who went to earth
yeah i went to earth mom yeah you went
to earth when you were here
aliens going through a bad breakup he's
in a high position of power who's saying
he doesn't make an emotional decision
push a button and we explode i don't
know
no but it is literally okay and here's
what i feel and then we can move on from
aliens if you want
i mean i i we i mean i'm enjoying it we
can move on but i
just don't know oh yeah like i just
don't get like
what's about to go on my question but
you think in our lifetime we're going to
get to a point where
more is revealed to the point where
we're openly communicating so
here's what here's here here's what i
want you to think about
with history and and this one i've been
thinking about for majority of history
for the majority of history
the things that we know right now that
are common knowledge the earth is round
there's outer space we revolve around
the sun the sun doesn't
revolve around us it's only the last
couple hundred years for the majority of
recorded history
they believe things that we'd be like
can you believe when they thought
right dragons were real and we revolt
and the sun voted on us
and all that thing so this was only 300
years ago the top
level scientists george washington his
doctors
believed when he got an infection that
the best possible thing to do for him
was to put leeches on him and suck his
blood out
that's what they thought was a great
idea and he died right these were the
top
men and women of the day we're making
these decisions
so we are living i believe in a
transitional time
where it is going to be common knowledge
for our children get it in
get it in no get in it i'm not trying to
i'm not trying to ham i shed you this is
not a speed bump keep talking
what we we we are living we are living
in a time where i genuinely believe our
children
it will be so common knowledge that
aliens are real that they will say
remember when our parents or
grandparents
thought that they weren't real that's
wild that's what i think the period of
time are you ready for that
are you ready for that i'm ready for uh
not only am i ready would you let your
daughter have an alien friend
yes i would let her date an alien right
now you would let her date an alien
right
right now because number one i'm
progressive you know and i'm forward
thinking yeah
uh number two i do believe that there we
are planet is dying and we will we will
need to find some type of
self-serving planet self-sustaining
planet and i think the aliens are the
one to take i think
i think it's going to be a race between
the aliens and the chinese who gets to
the
new self-sufficient planet first so
right now if you ask me
i would prefer she could take whomever
she wants but if possible
go alien or chinese perfect she gets
good in with an alien or a chinese you
might be sad because then we could get
off the planet and i could survive
getting off the planet
because right now it's going to die so
are there the total recall the girl with
three boobs is by the way
the the number one thing i masturbated
to as a as a as a
number one i remember seeing uh seeing
it for the first time and i was
delighted
and i remember that even to this day i'm
still delighted yeah because i mean it's
absolutely you're never ready for it
no it's third boobs yeah you're never
ready for it and even when you see the
movie again you're always like
yeah wow it's intriguing it's it doesn't
turn you off
no right if a woman had three boobs i
would have no prop that would be fine by
me
yeah yeah who is that by the way now
look is that a famous actress
who has the three boobs is it is it
pam grier no okay no no sorry
in in the movie total recall yes is it
pam greer the
well i know who pam guru is that that's
not pancreas she's pam greer is a black
actress oh maybe she's not okay all
right oh my god
is that was that is it doesn't it look
like pam grier oh maybe it is it doesn't
look yeah what can you do
you're right uh was that her no
no i no must not be
i but yeah so so you think about so you
you think that they have pets
aliens yeah they have pets there's got
to be a species
on the planet other than them yeah
because how progressive are they that's
a good point
are they racist do they do they have the
same imperfections as humans have are
they sexist
right you know do they segregate like
are they do they have their like
is their world like do they have
ethnicities and nationalities
like you know you know they like oh here
come the right you know like
you know i don't even know like these
are people from another land look at
like you know we don't i don't know
yeah will we know i
don't know what i'll i don't know but i
do know on this planet
we're very we're very progressive to the
point where
even if you make an alien like i made an
alien joke
on twitter today and i called them the
greens
and people were saying that's a racist
and i should really think about it
yeah and i said they said yeah and i
said i said that if the airlines are
real joe biden will put them in his
cabinet
and to fear the greens and and and uh
and so so
i would say that's positive stuff though
for our society that that's how
progressive we are
is we're saying aliens which aren't even
confirmed to be real you can't be
you can't even make fun of them you
can't even make it because they have a
place they have a safe space
i hope they have a sense of humor i hope
that they have to if they've been
watching us you know
yeah it says the lady who was uh the
actress from
uh with the three breasts from total
recall wishes
people would just forget it
like she imagine imagine that that life
sentence how many people do you do it
and she's like you know
my big break it's great there's even
like special effects i'm this unique
carrier
character i got three boobs it's gonna
be a memorable scene in the movie and
for 40 years now people are just calling
like three titty james yeah three
titties people just walked up and go are
you the woman with three boobs with
total recoil and then you go
how many times has she been in a
relationship and gotten into with
someone and they then they brought it up
yeah it's true it's true elon musk could
very well be an alien very very possible
looks like an alien let me ask you this
when aliens do come out as real because
i believe that it could happen
it could happen like in the next in
months time it could be
are they going to go on a talk show is
an alien are going to go on kelly ripa
is alien just going to go on kelly ripa
yeah and say
what's up and come out and do they're
doing a cookbook absolutely and i've
been on kelly ripa
you've been on kelly ripa yes a few
times
i've been on kelly right a few times
actually i don't have
not actually the time that i was on
kelly ripa there was one time with
uh i think with stray hand one time
around secrets there was one time that
chris pratt
was with chris pratt yes was this chris
pratt
uh movie star jack hunk chris super star
jack tonkris
chris patterson it was when the
magnificent seven was out the remake of
the western movie oh yes it was like um
uh morgan freeman now is he two because
he because he's obviously muscular guy
leading that
tall or short um he was not
crazy tall but maybe a little taller
than i maybe about your height maybe
yeah i could be wrong but
from what i gleaned see to me that just
that just felt like a shot at me because
i thought that i was
tall you are tall you just said chris
pratt not really that tall
well he's not like uh towering where
it's like well that's a big
he's not six seven he's not like a vince
vaughn the reason why i bring it up is
because for me
conan for i guess from my own coping
strategies when i see a guy like a chris
pratt
who seems like he has it all he's he's
jacked he's ripped he's
he's the lead of movies i just say what
maybe he's short and i'm taller than him
and at least i have that
yeah but i understand what you're saying
what i'm saying yeah but you know what
he was a former like chunky guy
right and i love him because he gives a
good name for all of us right he just
shows you like if i get a contract to be
in guardians of the galaxy
and i and someone like lets me work out
for a couple of years i could maybe be
like oh no
also everyone reveres him as a
sweetheart i believe it to be true
i i'm going to say this loud and clear
if i ever
get a lead role in a movie yeah you
won't be able to stop me my family
zombie
i'm immediately taking steroids i will
immediately inject hgh into my body
and testosterone and you i will there is
no
shot in hell i'm not taking
performance-enhancing drugs
if i'm going to be the lead of a movie
that's just what it is yeah and i think
they all must you think that'll help
with your acting shops too
yeah because like is it all around like
just a super like a super drug
i think it might be jacked and you might
also have like more emotional more
emotional yeah
and yeah and uh yeah i mean look at how
he gets ripped good guys that's right i
mean
positive okay so kelly first of all did
you know he's gonna be on kelly ripa i
don't i think they let us know yeah
because i knew
yes yes i did know because he was the
guest host and uh
morgan no not morgan for freaking denzel
washington washington was in magnificent
seven
uh with him and um he was gonna be the
first guest that day
okay and here's the bad news right off
the bat i don't remember in what context
i might have went to a wedding but i
never i
this might have been one of the last
times in the last five six years that
i've even been hungover in my life
like i've maybe been at home over like
two or three times in less time i've
known you
i've known you very well for i'd say
about five years hung out with you
quite often i would say maybe i've seen
you drunk
once or twice yeah in five years it
doesn't happen a lot you know whatever
so anyway i show up we got you got to be
there at like 6 a.m
and and i was up for a large portion of
the night before
and i went in and i was you know that
you know the hungover when
you will cry in someone's face you don't
even know oh yeah i got there they
checked me and i went through the
security like my hands were shaking yeah
i was trying not to know my mouth was
dry i was chugging water
and i was so shaking it was brutal i was
like we got there and they're like
you go on around like you know 9 40. it
was like 7 30. yeah and i'm like
is there a room in this building that is
quiet and dark and i can go to
and they brought me to a room and i went
to sleep on like three chairs pushed
together yeah
and then someone came and got me like an
hour and a half later right
that's how you fall asleep did you
actually i was out and i woke up and i
still felt terrible like it didn't help
in a smidge
it didn't help it didn't help and i and
i was like oh this is gonna be bad i was
actually worried that i might throw up
on camera right right
very rarely do you see somebody drinking
out of a a water jug like that a
thermostat
what kind of what would you call that
what would you call that a water flow a
flask
a water flask a water flask very flask
hydro
you very rarely see that live on a
podcast but there yeah but you know what
it is i should do that on the patreon
that's where people should
drink more water and i had that didn't
drink no i don't even worry about it
i'll drink one with you i bought this
i bought this part because what happened
was in bed i used to try to drink and
every night i was spilling all over
myself
so i bought this and now the straw goes
down to the bottom
shout out
[Laughter]
there we go the bluetooth i have such a
boner that it hit the switch off promo
code hey babe
so so exactly right so
so so i'm like i got to do something i'm
not able to sustain this interview
right so let me just i need to need
something right now so
i might have been still drunk i think
okay and i said you know it'll be funny
i i i had is this you and the guys or is
this it's just
me and the guys but this idea is only my
own and i was like i want to do this bit
let's see if it works let's see if it
works okay
and for some reason because until
washington was on and they were talking
about the magnificent seven
you want to talk about hunks of the
century denzel washington and chris
pratt
yeah you that's a score of that's that
you got lucky it's unbelievable
i'm like this guy you know the two and
even so i'm like i'm so excited
let me do something memorable yeah so i
had the idea
let me go someone ran to this corner
store for me
and bought a pack of hanes undershirts
hanes
white undershirts like 100 colors like
michael jordan like fruit of the looms
yeah exactly right and i got a black
sharpie and i wrote
the magnificent seven with a sharpie on
a hanes t-shirt
and i put it on and i went out in that
shirt like i was i was
my joke was gonna be like i'm doing
everything i can to plug this movie for
you guys
and i misspelled magnificent and i
misspelled seven on purpose
on purpose okay i thought that would
even be funnier so i'm like i'm gonna
walk out there
in this shirt that says the magnifi
magnificant savann
and chris pratt's gonna jump all over it
and we're going to have
like something to talk about right off
the top yeah it'll be a bond between us
he's going to pick up i'm lobbing him a
softball yeah it's a haines shirt with
black sharpie it says the magnificent
you threw out assault you were willing
to get little league's elbow right then
and there right to throw this
we'll talk about magnificent seven it'll
endear me to them they'll talk about how
i spelt it wrong
maybe i admit it maybe i don't it'll be
fun it'll make a nice clip for the
internet no
no okay so send it up i love it i love
it with this building too because i have
never seen this clip but i'm genuinely
excited
this clip is short this looks good did
the guys say that silas is a bad idea
no they were like uh you know not do it
like it won't be funny just like do it
gotta do it yeah so i spelled it out
let me get the corner i spelled it out
in my handwriting i took off my
outfit for the show you know usually you
get a little more dressed up yeah and i
put on this undershirt it's unbecoming
okay and as we're watching it
in the beginning if you know them if you
know this show even back to the days of
regis they give away a vacation they're
always righteous
all right god bless you great straight
register um and they tell people like
look under your seat you used to tell
them when i was growing up they say look
under your seat number 75
and then seat 75 would look on there and
there was like a trip or whatever and
they would win
so they did a trivia with this woman at
the top of the show
and she didn't answer the question right
it was like a softball question she
didn't answer right
she loses the trip do you remember what
the question was any idea
it might be in the clip at the beginning
of this clip and
it was something that like a lot of
people knew i think yeah and it was so
disappointing that she got it wrong it
was like yeah and then
chris pratt goes the whole one's like oh
and he's like oh i'm so sorry but you
know what go on the trip anyway give it
to her give it to her
but would he like chris was going to pay
for it no he just was like i give her
the trip anyway like he told the show
like who cares if she got it wrong yeah
what he didn't realize was when you're
giving away prizes
it becomes state like a state thing it
comes a legal thing
so you can't give it away if the person
lost it's the same concept as game shows
so he said that out loud and then they
immediately told him no no no no we
can't do that it goes against the law
live on the air this happened live
yeah and he goes oh i can't do that and
he was little anyways i'm so sorry and
then everyone was like really awkward
and then he goes
you know what uh just go anyway i'll pay
for it beautiful
so everyone's like oh my god chris pratt
yeah and then kelly was like yeah
you know what honestly it's you know
it's our show together i'll take 50
i'll split it with you and then it's
like oh my gosh
yeah it was like you know six grand or
something like that yeah
so then denzel comes out right and
denzel's like hey how you doing and
they all know each other and he's in the
movie with him and he goes i heard about
what happened with the thing
i want to let you know i'll go in with
you guys anyways
the police goes nuts yeah my god denzel
they're going to this pool this woman
you know people are really nice
you know love wins and uh and i was like
oh i'm going out there i know what i'm
doing i was hung over as [ __ ] and i was
like
the second they say the second we sit
down
genius i say i want to just preempt this
interview hi everyone good morning i
hope you're doing well i'm going to tell
you right off the top
i'm not going in four ways for this
latest vacation i'm not doing it
like i'm not going to be strong-armed
into doing it and i thought
it would be gang busters
you know you know that like you know
that clip on the internet when someone
disses someone that's all the guys being
like oh
yeah yeah the guy goes like right in
front of the camera
oh yeah it's like oh [ __ ] yeah just like
goes right yeah i thought the crowd it
was gonna be like a deaf comedy jam
it's it's it's 9 00 a.m it's a morning
show nobody's
nobody's really like like really killing
it with jokes and everything you know
it's very tough i'm like let me go out
there let me just like because everybody
like just goes with the flow
i said i'm to go out there i'm going to
tell her no way i'm paying for this [ __ ]
right
so mind you i come out that's the first
thing i say
right and the audience is like haha and
it it immediately
like ends and then kelly's like no don't
worry she'll get it and she kind of took
it like half serious right and it dies
right down in there like the joke isn't
even that good and i know it's me great
and then i'm sitting there in a hanes
shirt with the misspelled name and
everything
and i see him look at it like i see him
look at it and i'm like looking at him
and then nobody ever brings it up
[Laughter]
it is never mentioned we don't talk
about it i we do the interview we get
out
they don't and i'm sitting there with a
hanes t-shirt with
sharpie marker it says the magnificant
seven on savann
and the the whole segment ends and i
leave
and it's never brought up so okay sure
dude so okay we gotta watch this clip
yeah yeah let's
see if you if you go to the beginning
you'll see them giving it away
impractical jokers so before we start
i'm not going four ways on the trip with
the lady i'm sorry
it's all right she'll be fine she'll be
fine she's gonna get her trip
by the way this is just the edited thing
of like the clip that's not the whole
segment
but you see how quiet it got yeah that's
how quiet i want to hear it again i want
to hear it again rewind it
impractical joker so before we start i'm
not going four ways on the trip with the
lady i'm sorry
all right she'll be fine she'll be fine
she's gonna get her tripped
then i'm there like dry mouth don't
throw up and now i bombed on that one
now they think this idiot
no one there is like oh we get it it's
sarcasm like they laughed a little bit
but i think they would
they would have been like that was funny
but he should have just done it like
that's what i do
so it's already a dud and then i'm
already like literally swaying like
please don't vomit please don't vomit
and then they don't bring up my hanes
t-shirt i went on national television
in an undershirt and they just didn't
bring it out did you feel
horrible for the rest of the day because
of that dude i
i felt terrible i felt i felt like an
idiot
and i'm just like i i was trying to help
like i was trying to i was trying to
throw them a lob like i just was
i thought they were going to tee off on
my shirt and like right after we're like
were you like to the guys were like was
that bad was that bad was it like
crack it up because even when we were
saying goodbye i i went to go you know
you exchanged some pleasantries sure and
i and i tried
look at the shirt magnificant savant the
magnificent and you even puffed your
chest out so the camera would get
excited
good shot i've adjusted my shirt to call
attention to it and i saw chris pratt's
eyes
read it and i saw him have a moment of i
mean
outright confusion and let me just like
i'm not even going to touch it i'm not
going to touch it
did you actually write this yourself or
did like a pa or my handwriting
wow not bad by the way does anybody in
the comments go down and say wow that
bond or what the hell is sal doing
i scrolled no one said a goddamn thing
no one said anything
an award they didn't even say anything
about my joke this 8 000 comments
they just talk about chris pratt and and
denzel well it's very easy
not many people can outshine usually
when sound the jokers are on something
it's about them
i would say chris pratt and denzel are
two of the people that
may just be oh i don't give a [ __ ] but
talk to talk about them but they i'm
saying they didn't talk about the fact
that i denied the trip and and had a and
had a magnificent savanna shirt on you
ha
i don't know if you have done this
already you should sell those shirts as
merch
is that the merch is that the merch joe
that's the merch
if honestly if i still have that shirt
somewhere we can get the exact
like my exact handwriting reprinted on
on a new shirt and we could sell
magnificent
savan shirts beautiful yeah i now have
you been on
ripa since then did you mention that no
this is yours and so i didn't mention it
and i learned my lesson by the way
i just came out i smiled and i and i and
i talked about like you know
fruit cake or something and i left
whatever you have to do yeah all right
well there you go the magnificent savon
sal bombed on kelly rip
with this podcast we literally always
have a laundry list of things to talk
about and we get to maybe one usually
zero
yeah yeah we're done baby all right so
we gotta plug anything oh no i mean well
at hey babe on instagram uh please
follow us
um youtube.com no press network or
search no pressure network on youtube
uh we got taste buds on there with salad
joe derosa you got hey babe
with me and sal um and you can go to my
website christy comedy.com i got a bunch
of live dates coming up
so check out your baby boy yeah and uh
what else i guess i'm at south volcano i
i
i started this new thing called
community we could talk about it another
time it's an
app where i have a phone number that
goes to my phone so i wanted to talk
about that because it's been a really
unique one i have it as well
you got me into it i have it you have it
i have it let's talk about it on another
episode yeah
yeah but my my my number uh for that
show is is that kind of what i want to
play you can text sale 718
260 and i'll explain what the hell that
is in another episode but
that is the number that goes to my phone
that i could actually text with you guys
with
and we'll get into it another time you
have some weird experiences with it but
um yeah
so there you go and uh what else the
the pod drops every thursday for hey
babe comes out every thursday
11 a.m eastern time so hit the subscribe
button
on our youtube no pressure network and
what we're doing is it's
especially it comes out everywhere you
get podcasts audio-wise
and it's always going to come out
immediately the full episode on youtube
we kind of just uh we were deciding
where to go with it yes and then we
we realized the best way to go would be
to just put it out and make our patreon
something more exclusive right and extra
not just the episode on video
we want everybody to see the video on
youtube share it rate us subscribe
comment all the things that you can for
us follow us on spotify like it
tell your friends most importantly tell
your friends um and this has been one
two three
hey baby